um so where do you want to take low
blood TV
um honestly
um that Joe Rogan bad right so it's not
just about low blood TV it's talker
media is where we focus on low blood TV
is a show under talking it's one of the
shows it's one of the shows we also have
he say shishay Okay shout out to my
brother little goofy and my sis Haley
they have a dope ass show on our um
channel on our uh platform it's called
he say she say when y'all get a chance
tweak on it but I wanted Joe Rogan back
we want that job yeah we want it we want
it you can't come pay little blood you
gotta pay talker media you know do you
want somebody to come and just bag you
out for the company yeah so for you is
it because again we I feel like you're
gonna get to a point where you're gonna
have to hit the road we already do that
that's what I was gonna say because
there's I just saw you backstage what
show were you backstage in uh Jean
Perico right yeah yeah yeah yeah uh G
pre-con Richie yeah
um but I do feel like
and this is a conversation I'll be
having with guys we just hit the road
have you seen ghazi's podcast Studios
he's building yeah yeah yeah for sure
matter of fact um shout out Ghazi I was
just having a hard conversation with
gazi about doing some business with him
with that yes for sure so I'm gonna
start doing like a episode a week out
there okay cool but I think that the
there's gonna be to like expand
unfortunately it's not a lot of people
going to the Bay unless they're going to
do something that's what I told I told
like I told Ghazi I said people are
coming to the Bay
and they got a itinerary so it's like
hard to squeeze in a two-hour long-form
conversation into that itinerary as
opposed to like
people living in L.A right New York
right right right right you know what
I'm saying have you noticed like have
you ran into that
issue where it's like [__] I could do an
interview with this person but I only
got 20 minutes or you know
um honestly
um
in all places do the God but like but if
you know me and people like really like
they people are really not giving me
like that like people changing schedules
to do my [__] like
um
or even just like access to certain
guests that you must yeah so shout out
Nano shout out my brother Nano uh
milsies you ever heard of him who from
uh Boston oh Millie's yeah yeah Millie's
my bad
um my brother Nano had called me like
hey bro you want to interview bro you
[__] with you you know I told him about
it like Yeah well yeah here in L.A we
drove right up knocked it up got you so
you'll do you'll I'm traveling but I
need the boola calves you feel me I need
the the atoms like give me the game bro
like I'm a student of this [__] like
y'all are who I study like I pay
attention to y'all I watch y'all [__] I
watched a million dollars worth of games
like I'm I'm studying y'all and if
if y'all not giving us the game or y'all
not helping it's like it's no it's no
point it's like you feel me it's it's a
bagging and [__] for everybody for sure
like everybody and I hate The
Gatekeepers that keep the gate closed
like you know yeah yeah no I mean listen
I didn't even know there was a
gatekeeper thing in the podcast world
man that's a gatekeeper thing anywhere
bro come on you know how that [__] go
like everywhere right it's politics bro
people play and it's weird but like I
said it would have been Boosie of you it
wouldn't it wouldn't have costed you
nothing like or if you would have been
like nah [__] and you know are you
talking to little Russell not even
bringing it up like damn I [__] with
Bloodshed like I think he got a dope you
feel me like you couldn't have said
nothing you get what I'm saying like and
by you just giving a [__] his flowers
that opened up oh what you think you
need it y'all know he dope as [__]
music and they have you go tap in you
feel me like that type of [__] and what
I mean by Gatekeepers it's like
the uh drink Champs you know the
household names right you guys are the
you know The Gatekeepers that's how I
look at it and and like I said it's it's
on you guys and I'm not saying just go
find some random [__] oh yeah
I'm gonna put you on my [__] no I see
you working I see you serious you
[__] around come on let's build let's
Network you get what I'm saying yeah I
think I think for you you're just gonna
have to hit the road a lot yeah and I'm
ready and we do that we do that because
I think I think the thing about like
like I said like
the tour I feel like Torah routing has
changed a lot as to where like there's
not as many rap tours as there used to
be there's a lot of people doing spot
dates there's a lot of people hopping on
bigger tours but like I feel like even
like five six seven years ago there was
just everybody would tour and I feel
like the touring should just kind of
slowed down and I just think the
opportunity to like sit down with a lot
of people in the bag
is gonna it's gonna kind of you're gonna
be kind of running a one a one leg race
initially so what you're gonna have to
do is
make the [__] pop move around do the
bass [__] if you gotta go to La if you
got to go to Atlanta if you got to go
here you got to go here and then little
Blood TV becomes the destination okay to
where now it's like oh not if I'm going
to Cali we gotta go to the bathroom we
have to go sit down with oh it's a 45
minute flight it's a six hour drive so
now you're
amongst okay if I'm planning my press
run
I know I have to go to California and
not just go to and I think that's the
goal of what gazi's trying to do is like
have a whole
infrastructure of media Outlets
that is San Francisco based right right
towards like cool now when you come to
the Bay you can go do a little Blood TV
bootleg cab is going to be there uh and
then you know whatever new shows gazi
develops because we want to develop some
new new shows to populate that floor so
I think that's kind of the the bigger
picture is like I gotta get this [__]
super hot
and now people gonna have to come right
right and that's and mind you we're only
in a year right a hundred percent you
know what I'm saying so um you should do
way more I would love to see you do more
show athletes because I think the
Marshawn Lynch is dope I was just like I
was just telling somebody I was like yo
why is the Marshawn Lynch done a podcast
right right that [__] we go quick
Draymond Green's running it up right
right right right right right running it
ah right right well um you know be small
films man we families right yeah I just
be like if he got on during the he could
just be football season if if Marshawn
Lynch were to go the I am athlete or
pivot route it'd be the biggest [__] in
sports
yeah I think it'd be crazy shout out to
Marshawn because he's like a
one-of-a-kind person yeah definitely
definitely definitely even like I was
like talking to RJ about I was like yo
why doesn't 40 do like drink Champs
before you be drunk right you know what
I'm saying boy he's the drunkest
[__] I know bro every time I see
40 he is sluricaned out you know what
I'm saying like I'm like bro imagine if
40 sat down with an artist once a week
and just they drank their wine because
you know he loves that one right have
you done drink Champs yet like no I mean
I'm I almost uh so
I was drink Champs was supposed to do a
network
um and I was supposed to sign with
Noriega as like because I announced I
was going to launch a podcast in
probably 2018 and Nori had hit me and
he's like don't do it yet I'm putting
this network together and I wanna I want
you to be one of the first guys we
signed ended up not working out I kind
of like sat on my hands waiting for it
to
whatever deal
to shake out that he was working on a I
don't want to say with who but he had
like a couple of people he was working
on his Network deal with
um didn't end up happening and I was
just like dude
I'm trying to do my thing like I'm gonna
just do this [__] like I got a studio I
got like I got everything I need you
know what I mean so
um so yeah no but I'm real tight with
Nori that's my dog um but I haven't gone
to drink I mean I've been to episodes of
dream Champs off camera you know I've
hung out and it's a Vibe for sure it is
a it is a lot of energy
but I think if you don't I don't think
40's done dream Champs yeah I'm not sure
more I don't know man I could be wrong I
feel like that would that's gonna happen
I'm not sure but yeah man but not
definitely you're doing your thing
you're on the right path man appreciate
it appreciate it everything's high
quality
you know what I'm saying your team over
here is killing the production
appreciate it appreciate it so when you
hit the road you just take the the light
with you right no hell no we take our
whole [__] no but I mean like you're set
always has the light no matter what so
that's dope so you can just do that [__]
anyway yeah hell yeah hell yeah talk to
me you're like a little Blood TV like
hell yeah definitely it's just you know
like you said marketing and branding and
we're just trying to keep we're trying
to be a household name we're not trying
we're gonna be I don't believe in Corona
crime or anything like that I believe in
manifesting [__] so if I just keep
speaking on this [__] yeah manifesting
like I manifested this yeah I think you
guys have such a dope like I feel like
you know I try to have the um the
Stockton guys on my show I had a GB from
Modesto yeah
I had another kid from Modesto that I
saw the Russell's house freestyle and I
just invited him up to Freestyle what
was that kid's name he's 16. he came up
here with his dad oh yeah he's raw he
got dreads fire yeah yeah he's raw as
[__] yeah I know he's talking about but
I think that like there's so much going
on just in Northern California that like
it's nice that you have a dope platform
to like
throw some of them alley Hoops too for
sure because I think I think dizzler
does a good job with this for sure [__]
care bro what am I saying me with the
the Freddie Gibb [__] bro so don't just
say for sure and you know I'm talking
about alley Hoops bro because I'm a dish
you you weren't the only person I
canceled that day yeah I forget who else
it was I'm the only person that caught
you
I mean I wasn't not sick
I was I wasn't I wasn't well he asked
him Drank in his hand [__] these [__]
that ain't sick
hey man it was I had to make sure I knew
what kind of night it was going to be I
had to get my rest
I had to get my rest yeah I knew it was
going to be a nightlife I need them
alley hoops man and I'll throw you some
alleys too man now yeah I got to come
out there that's crazy mozzie was going
to come with me too right now
he's out finally what was it about a
year a little under a year was it yeah
yeah he was gonna come
I said nah I can't hate her hey there's
a reason why I have that plaque there
yeah it's on camera I said let me go
Philly my first man let me go see I love
that's my brother man he's a great guy
man I'm happy definitely definitely
happy he's home man I appreciate you
pulling up uh what's the IG what's the
uh my personal IG third world low blood
3rd wrld
that's if you want some dope ass music
you feel me you're gonna follow that
page boom little Blood TV it's my
podcast page
l-i-l-b-l-o-o-d TV that's the podcast
page Tiger Media
t-h-a-k-u-r-m-e-d-i-a that's where you
get all the he say she says the
everything you need to know about little
blood whatever go to talker media you
tap in with them for management whatever
the case you need me to do talker media
who Bert Jones